hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar phenotyping the tumor
microenvironment using
dna barcoded multiplex technology
i'm susie valdez of labyrinths and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by
lab roots and brought to you by leica
biosystems
to learn more about our sponsor visit
them at www.leicabiosystems.com
so let's get started i'd like to remind
everyone that this event
is interactive and we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
also please notice that you can share
this webinar on your personal social
media
just click on the social sharing tab and
let your friends and colleagues know
about today's live event if you have any
trouble seeing
or hearing this presentation simply
click on that support tab found
at the top right of your presentation
window or report your problem by
clicking the
ask a question box located on the far
left of your screen
this presentation is educational and
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credit
i now present today's speaker
chef son shepay is a senior
histotechnologist with g
s k r d for a complete biography on our
speaker please visit the biography
tab at the top of your screen to say
welcome
you may now begin your presentation sir
hello everyone i am
senior history technologist with
jessica as a platform our team
uses multiple modalities
such as immunohis chemistry flow
cytometry
ngs to increase our understanding of
biomarkers in both normal and diseased
conditions
will develop optimize and validate
various acids
supporting studies from first time in
human to
physical clinical trials specifically
i'm responsible for
immunohis chemistry immunofluorescence
inside your hybridization and multiplex
today
i'm gonna share some of my recent
experience using
d barcode multiplex technology to
phenotype
tumor micro environment
before i get started a statement i have
no
conflict of interest with lack about
system
out view and any collapse all materials
used in this presentation are for
educational purpose only
the human body examples were sourced
aesthetically and their research use was
in accord with the terms
of the informed consent and irb
ec approved protocol
here are some learning objectives i hope
by the end of this presentation you will
be able to
understand the complex of tumor
microenvironment
and its importance in drug development
introduce how to view dna barcoding and
exchange technology for multiple
multiplex immune fluorescence last but
not least
highlights the processes of immune image
fusion
spatial analysis and co-localization of
markers
on individual cells
first let's have a look at what is uh
my tumor micro environment
the tumor mass consists of not only
of a heterogeneous population of cancer
cells
but also a variety of relevant and
infiltrating
host cells secretive factors and
extracellular magics collectively known
as
tumor microenvironment blood vessels
supply oxygen and nutrients
to the tumor
along the vessel there are enzo cellular
cells
and the cellular cells fibroblasts and
parasites
innate and adapted immune cells
like macrophages nk granulocytes
lymphocytes were frequently found in the
tumor microwave
these cells secrete chemokines
cytokines interlude interleukins
that regulate immune civilians tumor
suppression
hybrid tumor cells also have developed a
set of mechanisms
to evade immune civilians for example
myeloid derived suppression cells
regulatory
t cells microphones they also
were able to produce factors to suppress
immune response empire antigen present
antigen presenting block t cell
trafficking
and activation tumor progression is
profoundly
influenced by interaction of
cancer cells with their environment
which ultimately
determine whether the tumor is
eradicated
continues to grow or my tester size
the chamomile environment is a dynamic
structure
which can shift therapeutic response and
resistance justifying the reason
in patterns to target components of
tumor microenvironment
one of the examples of was the success
with the success of
immune checkpoint inhibitors this map
this map shows you the landscape of
current immunotherapy
on the most outside cycle
there are treatments that have been
approved or
anti-active clinical development some of
them
are very well known like the p1 pdr-1
cdl is4 molecular antibodies they have
been
shown to be effective for multiple
cancer types
the inner blue and green cycles
are the respective targets pathways
and mechanism of action the clinical
outcomes in patients
are significantly affected by the
immune factors of the tumor based on the
infiltrated immune cell type density
their location and function we can
briefly divide
this map into three categories
part code and altered
currently approved checkpoint inhibitors
work best in patients
with hot tumors only
a small portion of patients can benefit
from this treatment
for patients with
code or altered tumors
alternative treatments should be
considered
problem is how to stratify the patient
give each the most effective treatment
and predict the clinical outcomes
the answer relies on biomarkers
a biomarker is a marble substance in
an organism whose presence is indicative
of some phenomena
such as disease infection or
environmental exposure throughout the
development of pharmaceutical rnd
biomarkers
can help improve decision making process
this map shows you the process of
a drug from target validation
to kind of selection first-time human
and
undergo several rounds of clinical
trials
all the way to clinical
to regulatory approval
even at the very beginning of
as the target validation
you should the scientists should begin
to consider
strategies for bond markets such as
pharmacodynamics
surrogate or clinical biomarkers also in
canada selection you can use biomark
data from
in-vivo and pre-clinical models to
evaluate the compound advocacy and
model human dosing in clinical trials
you will implement
the bond market strategy and test the
half of
the value of biomarkers to predict
and the disease progression
so in later clinical development you
first pass the value of biomarkers to
the clinical outcomes
immunological chemistry is one of the
methods to study biomarkers
the current method
is using single plex immunity chemistry
to evaluate the biomarkers on sections
it is they are
used because they can be evaluated using
a standard branches microscope
and their more morpholi details are
present
to aid the interpretation
however there are some limitations of
single plaque's chromogenic
immunoglobulin which drives for
multiplex for example because
the core the boxy samples are relatively
very tiny
they are very precious so normally there
will
be limited amounts of piston tissue
you want to use multiplex to save these
samples
also multiplex will facilitate the
demonstration of co-localized markers
and their measurements using image
analysis
as we go towards
basic workflow and multiple multiplex
image analysis
so we can get the special information
for cell cell interaction the multiplex
also
will reduce stock of consumers and
reduce waste
going forward single plaque's immune
system will
still be valuable at the very beginning
of the assay development
so you select the panel of hrp dies that
are capable of
single flex ifc on the ventana or
like a bond instrument then you evaluate
best practice by testing various
approaches they establish guidelines for
selecting
optimal multi multiplex immune
fluorescence approach
so currently on the market there are
quite a few options available for
example
the hrp pyramid technology which are
available from ventana
and aquarium opal type detection
so there's another technology from cell
iodx they used
modified hampton to label their primary
and anabolic then you can
use antihypertense secondary to detect
your
target so the fourth one is
using dna box to label primer primary
antibodies so
how to have developed a very good
technology based on this
so this will be the focus of this
presentation
today
here are some advantages of rtu method
over conventional immunohis chemistry
first it's high specificity since each
and body is packed with a unique idea in
barcode linker
all the primary antibodies are
cocktailed
together and applied to a single
solution and you could incubation step
that use this will save you a lot of
time
this technology is non-spacious
dependent detection so
you don't have to worry about selecting
and quenching
or diminishing any species of secondary
antibodies
it's timeline and hip-free detection
the background will be very relatively
low
from free from
endogenous proxies the signal
is amplified it's very bright
the protocol is randomized uh fully
automated on
bond rx the whole process can be
completed with less than
six hours
this is a brief overview of
outview four plex ic
after ux and ending interval your
cocktail of primal antibodies will be
applied
onto the section this each of these and
frame antibodies were labeled with a
unique dna barcode
so which allows them to be recognized
specifically
in this step understanding
you the the gene the barcode on the
primary envelope will be amplified
significantly which allows
which allows a better
signal to noisy result
then last step detection
you will use a mixture of
frozen labels or props which
were complementary to the gene
dna packs so you can visualize
your target as conventional
immune fluorescence so remember all
these steps can be done
in single one step you don't have to
worry about
several rounds of primary antibody
incubation
or stripping the whole process can be
done within 6 hours
this workflow is a
an automated fully automated workflow
for
this ac so right right now the
rtu has developed a optimized protocol
on
bond rx so after
the scanning we will image the slides
using vector players scanner
after we the scanning will check
the images for quality and consistency
so after that the curved sleeve can be
removed
and then for uh additional
ate staining then you can
register and fuse
your eighty with multiplex immune
fluorescent
then for further image analysis
at the start we purchased two
ready-to-use
panels from our views for testing
the first one is pd1 second one is pdl1
so on p1 panel we have
cd45 ro for memory t cells
pd1 for exhaustive or
suppressed suppressive t cells cd3 for t
cells on pdr1 panel we have
cd8 for cytotoxic t cells
cd60 for macrophages pdl1 for immune
checkpoint
marker so on both panels pencil key
and suction will be used as a tumor
cell and epithelial cell marker
slides show you a simple
uh rtu protocol on bonner on rx
it is fully automated
after baking and dwax followed by
year on2 and in two for 20 minutes
you can apply rtu region solutions
onto your sections so followed by a
brief
antibody diluent blocking so you apply
your primary antibiotic cocktails on the
section and you keep it for 60 minutes
then followed by a quick
pre-amplification mix for 25 minutes and
then
a very robust signal amplification
for 90 minutes so before you apply
the fluorescent props a nuclear
constant will be applied onto the
section
so this is an example showing uh
sustaining in human tonsil city 45
in grain pb1 in orange so you can see a
lot of uh
p1 standing in german centers cd3 in
red a lot of cd3 plus itself inter in
interfollicle region 10 city were
labeled in white so on the right
you have pdr1 panel cd8
in green there's a lot of 3d positive
cells
in throughout this section cd68 in
orange
city pdl1 in red you see a lot of
uh colloquialization of pd
l1 with cd68 in the general centers
similarly pen ct
in white
so on this image we co-register
co-register the multiplex email verizon
with reference
80 together so on the 80
[Music]
images you can see
you can better visualize the anatomical
components and then cross-validate with
the
sending of macros on a
multi-plaximine fluorescence
then let's have a closer look at
this uh immune fluorescence and together
with 80
in order to better demonstrate the
staining of
each individual markers so i put the
markers into
separate channels here you can see a
very nice strong medium to strong memory
staining for
cd8 and cd6 cd68
a very nice uh intra-subtle uh plasma
staining
and for is expression
mainly localized on the epithelial cells
for plant ck and substance to this
labels the epithelial cells so in this
corner you see the
final colonization of this
imaging the same thing for our pdr1
panel
so cd45 pdr1 and c3 they have very
nice membrane staining so on this cone
you see
the colloquialization of pdy and cd3
so we also tested some human tumor
tmas so just to give you an example this
is a stomach tumor call so on this
pd one panel you see a very nice
colloquialization of cd3 with pdr1
cd3 with 45 ro strong
on the right you see a
very strong thing of cd8 and the cp-45
well the pdl1 expression will relatively
low
if we turn on the
tumor marker so you can see the spatial
relationship of this immune cells with
the tumor cells
so so far we have talked about uh spend
four marks on
one section so how about uh
doing more markers like eight markers
can we
um put one panel on top of
another one so the answer is yes so
autoview has developed a technology
using a gene exchange so
as shown on this uh
graph so you can see uh like
similarly like the four packs you apply
all
eight markers in a single uh
cocktail apply the c onto the section
then uh instead of visualizing all eight
so you will visualize
four of them individually
so in round one you apply uh
flow for profs on the section then
images
the section for these four markers
so after you finish the image then you
can remove the cup sleeve
and run the exchange protocol
then after that you can apply the second
set of
fluorescent props onto the section
we together with outview we have
developed a
mid to order seven plex ic
so we have on round one we have cd8
uh cd68 pdr1 on round two we have ks37
grand zone b
cd3 and pi and c key to
use cd3 cd8 and
to phenotype the cell types and grinds
on b
ksc7 pl1 were used as an expression
marker
we used a pencil key to label the tumor
as well as
a segmentation marker
so here's a list of the phenotypes we
looked at
so we analyzed
a single single positive double process
or triple positive
phenotypes on the section so
cell density percentage of cells
in the tumor and lung tumor were
reported respectively
after finish after finish understanding
we image the slides and send the images
to our pathology for on qc
and reviewing so here we actually
withstand
uh 20 blood
tumors and 20 uh nonsense lung cancers
here just to show you
the result for a bad tumor pathologists
evaluate the uh
the tumor space and classified as
them as cold hot or exclude
tumors so as you can see
from this table about 50 of the samples
were classified as excluded
25
for uh code and hot tumor age
here this is a and represented
representative imaging for hot immune
flame tumor tissues so
the tumor were labeled by a plan ck in
white
and cd8 positive cells in
green so you can easily see a lot of
cd8 t-cells within the tumor
also for you
there were a lot of uh cd8
and uh cd3 and cd68 positive uh
cells within tumor as well um
there was there was a very nice uh
colloquialization on pdl1 with
macrophages
and this is an example for our code
tumors
which is a immune deficient tumor
so you can barely see any uh
cd8 positive cells within on this
section
also there are very few cd3 and cd6a
positive cells on this section as well
this this is an example of for executed
for immune excluded tumor sections
so you on this section you can see a lot
of
cd8 cell infiltration in a
tissue but very few of them
were in within the tumor
similarly for c3 and cdacd68
positive cells none of them
were found in the within the tumor
this is a another example from
non-smarter lung cancer
with selected phenotypes as shown
[Music]
on the images you can see a very nice
colloquialization of
cd3 and cda with cd8
pdl1 colloquialized with
cd68 and pine ck so
also you can see uh the spatial
relationship between
these immune cells with with tumor
so after we get the images from round
one round two
so we fuse the images
together into one single image using
hello
after the diffusion we used
uh the tumor marker ct and that p cells
to classify
the tumor the tissue into tumor versus
lung tumor then we use
the hypex algorithm in halo to
detect the cells and perform
phenotyping analysis on the
each individual images
so halo actually provides a lot of uh
algorithm for for image analysis so uh
so here i use the high text algorithm
for analysis
so after setting up the threshold for
each marker then you can
determine your phenotypes through a
combination of
marker and channel positivity
after we finish the even image analysis
in hello so we send
the images together with the markup to
pathologies again to let them review
and qc the quality of analysis
so on most of the sections the algorithm
the algorithm successfully detects most
of the cells
with only their fuel cells to
fill because they are usually lost
during the second
round staining or lost by the fusion
segmentation artifact
so for cd3 cd8 cd60
the algorithm successfully detects up to
90 of all the cells which are very
sensitive so
further samples were access were
excluded from an
image analysis because of either
excessive autofluorescence or image
misalignment
so this here i show you some competitive
analysis
results for blood cancer
so on the right on the left is
the cell density analysis on right is
the percentage analysis
so from this graph you can say
the parasitic positive cells were
enriched in the tumor area while the
number
four of city positive cell was
relatively low in
long term cell which means the
halo classification algorithm works very
well to classify
tumor and the non-tumor the number of
cd68 positive cell
and cd3 cd8 positive cells
were comparable for the intent
for cell intensity uh the number was
around
400 to 500 per millimeter
the percentage was around five to ten
percent
but i think at the same time you also
know
uh will notice a lot of uh single
uh samples in with the radio high
uh cd60 and cd8 cells
so it means they probably will respond
better
to immunotherapy so
overall the number of grand lamb
positive cells were very
low on all of the samples
additionally we analyzed
[Music]
the number of the expression of
kia 37 pdry expression in
cytotoxic t cells macrophages and tumor
cells
most of the cd3 cd8 positive cells were
negative for both ksc7 and
pdl1 about 10 percent of
macrophages were positive for pdl-1
for sticky positive cells
they were there were more positive
kia cd7 and pdpr1 protein cells were
found
within the tumor compared to the
long-term area
then we plotted uh the percentage of two
tubes on on this graph and we
mapped the pass evaluation
and to this graph so you can see a
tumor in red dot a non-tumor in a
grain cube so uh this is uh
the whole tumor was represented by a
dotted box
excellent excluded gmo but in
blank box code tumor in not
not box here so basically we observed a
very
good concordance between
halo data with
past evaluations
to beside the cell normal quantification
you can
also play around a more special
analysis so here uh this
image shows you uh the distribution of
cd3 cd8 positive cells in the
blood tumor sample cd3ca
production cells in grain
pancake positive cells in yellow so the
black line annotated the area or
tumor area so based on this
image you can clearly tell this is a
hot tumor so you see there are a lot of
uh cd3c positive cells in both
in within and outside the tumor
then you can go ahead to analyze to
measure
the the distance of each toxic t
cells to to the nearest tumor cells
to eat so we analyzed the num
the the t cell cytotoxic t
cells within a 200 micron distance from
the tumor
so each line represents a pair of
t cells with its nearest tumor cells
so on the right graph you can see
this is a number of toxic t
cells within uh
this distance of uh from tumor so you
can tell
you can tell within 20
micron distance from the tumor there are
quite a lot of
toxicity cells with increase of the
distance
the number of t-cells decrease very
sharply
also you can similarly you can
find the nearest t cells for each tumor
cells
on this image so each
grey line represents a pair of
tumor cells with its nearest t cells
so you can measure the distance between
a t and
uh tumor cells so for this image the
average the average
distance around 23 micron
additionally you can perform an
efficient analysis to
count cda t cells in
each gradient zone and i identify
hot spots from the heat map this
plot on the right shows the density of
cda city cd3c t cells
in each zone to left meaning
inside tumor or to right meaning towards
stroma
again before doing any analysis make
sure you talk to your pathologist
and project leader to understand the
question
and hypothesize then select the most
appropriate
method for analysis
last but not least i like to
thank all my colleagues for their help
and constructive suggestions during
the whole process also i want to thank
leslie and daniela
for the help with image review qc and
classification
special thank you to like about system
for
sponsoring this webinar rtu and indica
labs for their
generous help during acidvant with that
i will stop here and take any questions
and thank you chafee for that
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have any questions you'd like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
so let's get started we have quite a few
questions
already coming in to say how do you
build your own
panel does it cost a lot
uh that's that's a good question so
actually we collaborate with
our tv before the marketing product
so we choose the panel markers for
immune
and tumor cells so the customer that
so actually recently rtu has just
released
a uvue panel so you they give you a list
of
uh over 30 different markers you can
choose from that list and make your own
panel
and prefer props from that so
right now i think the the price is uh
relatively very expensive
so from our experience so
it will cost you about 500
per slide
thank you for that and is unmixing
needed
for this um assay
do you see any bleed through from
adjacent channels
so actually i'm mixing is not needed for
this technology since
uh all the props were labeled with
uh fluffer dyes which
has a non-overlapping spectrum so you
don't have to
uh and mix them together with the
uh the narrow banded uh filters you used
for images like so it won't be a
big issue for to see any uh
please through
thank you jefe and again i want to thank
our audience for their live part
participation what's coming in does the
exchange call also strip off your
primary antibodies
and what is the efficiency for that
uh that's that's a great question so um
the dna
exchange protocol won't remove the
the uh the bounded uh primary anabolic
you just remove
uh all the uh fluffer props from wrong
one
and and this process is very gentle make
sure uh
uh your tissue integrity and the bounded
antibodies to remain on the section so
you don't have to worry about
the uh the efficiency
thank you for that and this dna elegance
were used in this assay
do you pre-treat the tissues with d and
i apologize dnase to remove antigenous
um dna oh that's
that's a great question actually we
we we don't uh pre-treat uh
the tissues with dnase since uh
each dna barcode is unique which you
cannot find
in human genome and this bucket has been
pre-screened for any human exogenous
exogenous uh dna sequence so
we we don't have to worry about the
non-specific signal from the dna
also you want to keep the human
intelligence dna for your counter
staining
um our next question how do you know
your dyes
only color the cells you want do you
mark them
one by one
so actually uh you label your own
targets using
highly specific antibodies this and this
antibody
was conjugated to dna barcode so you use
a
fluorescent tag labeled uh
another sequence which is complementary
to the balcony used so which
makes your uh binding is very specific
so you don't you don't do it uh
one by one you just use the antibodies
through through them on the tissue and
you
visualize them all together
thank you and again audience thank you
for your questions any questions you
cannot answer today
will be answered via email we have time
for a few more questions
how many cd8 cells are pdl
one are they tonsil or tumor
uh this this is a great question so
normally uh
pdr1 will be expressed on
tumor cells or immune cells so it
depends on
each disease condition so
on our case uh we observed very few
c82000 express pdl1
so our quantification give about
five around five percent positive uh
positivity for our pdl1 so actually
considering uh some infiltrating
cdft cells they interpret
in the pdl-1 positive tumor cells so
sometimes the the halo algorithm will
pick up a little bit uh
pdl1 standing from the neighboring tumor
cells so actually i think
the real number of uh pdl one positive
ct cell will be
below that five percent
okay perfect what about the application
of signal is it done over the slide
itself
or after illusion
the amplification is done uh before you
apply your uh
fluorescent prop so you start on the
slide
thank you jfe and regarding the
antibodies do we have to titrate those
antibodies for our kind of tissue
um no since uh
the ani the all the region comes
in in a kit so you don't have you don't
have to
further dilute anything so
since this acid has been pre-optimized
you just uh prepare your and i threw
them on your uh
bond rx that's it
wonderful and again all these great
questions coming in
japanese how many markers can be managed
in
parallel
parallel is it order markers
as you performed two sequential analysis
with
four markers so in
each round of thinning you will only
visualize
four markers this because this is
because
the limitation of the uh fluorescent
uh props so you know to not
get an overlap between uh each channels
you want to
so right now the voice run only four
marks will be visualized but
then you can have a second round then
you can
apply i mean stack them together to get
a
plex marker
thank you and our next audience member
wants to know
how easily can this be modified for
other markers like for example non-tumor
research
that's a good question uh so you can uh
ask out view to
customer label your primary anabolies
for you
then you can apply your your own
analysis for other purpose
like non-tumor studies
thank you and since the primary
antibodies are
still on the tissue after round two
is it possible to go back and add the
probes back to round
one i'm sorry
can you repeat that question sure
since the primary antibodies are still
on the tissue
after round two is it possible to go
back and add the probes back
to round one
theoretically uh it is possible because
all the anvils do uh bond uh
on the tissue so even after uh stripping
you remove all the fluorescent props you
can still uh reapply uh
the problem back to the section
thank you jose we have time for a couple
more questions
can this technology be used to study the
inflammatory
micro environment in tb and or other
viral infections
um there's this this technology is just
i think it's a general very general
technique you can basically
apply to any other areas
you're interested in so just make sure
uh
before you apply that make sure make
sure you have checked the uh
[Music]
the barcode specificity on your
on your uh
species of interested
thank you and jave we have time for one
more question
how is the application done over
slide
so between so the amplification is done
in between uh the primary enable
incubation
and uh constraining so you will
they have a a special
region so you apply uh your that region
directly onto
uh your section so this is a done
all done uh automatically on the slide
thank you so much to faye and thank you
for this informative presentation
would you like to provide any closing
remarks for our audience members before
we go
i just want to say thank you everyone
for taking time to
join this webinar what i share today
just based on my
own knowledge and experience so if you
want to
know more in-depth knowledge about this
technology please
reach out to the vendors so again uh
stay safe and do well
today thank you again for your time
today and for your important research
and i'd also like to thank
lavroot and our sponsor leica biosystems
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
and before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we didn't have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information provided at the time
of registration
and we would once again like to thank
jeffery today for this great
research and for this presentation this
webcast can be viewed on demand and
labyrinths will
alert you via email when it's available
for replay we encourage you to share
that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time take care bye
you